DEALERS.
BRIAN?
BRIAN: PETER, I APPRECIATE IT.
LET’S BRING IN CHAD WOLF.
HE WAS BASICALLY CALLED OUT,
FORMER ACTING DH, SECRETARY,
HERITAGE FOUNDATION VISITING
FELLOW.
THEY HAD TO REBUILD IT FROM THE
BOTTOM UP, THINGS ARE
DRAMATICALLY BETTER.
DO YOU HAVE A RESPONSE?
>> WELL, BRIAN, THANKS FOR
HAVING ME ON, AND I’LL JUST SAY
THE FACTS DON’T SUPPORT THAT
LUDICROUS CLAIM.
OFOFOBVIOUSLY, WE HANDED THEM A
SECURE BOARD, AND THE NUMBERS
ACROSS THE BOARD SHOW THE SYSTEM
WAS NOT BROKEN.
NOW THEY’RE GOING BACK TO THE
SYSTEM UNDER THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WHERE CATCH AND
RELEASE IS PREVALENT, THEY’RE
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO COME
INTO THE UNITED STATES EVEN
THOUGH THEY DON’T QUALIFY FOR
ASYLUM, AND THEN THEY ARE
BLOCKING I.C.E., LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIALS’ ABILITY TO REMOVE
THESE INDIVIDUALS.
IN FACT, THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS, AGAIN, GOING
BACK AND THEY ARE REINSTITUTING
A BROKEN IMMIGRATION SYSTEM, AND
THEY’RE TRYING TO PUT THAT BACK
INTO PLACE.
IT’S THE WRONG APPROACH, AND I
DON’T BELIEVE THAT THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE SUPPORT THAT.
BRIAN BRIAN YOU KNOW WHAT?
THE MENTION PRESIDENT DOESN’T
BELIEVE THAT EITHER.
HE SAID EXPECTATIONS WERE
CREATED WITH THE GOVERNMENT OF
PRESIDENT BIDEN THERE WOULD BE A
BETTER TREATMENT OF MIGRANTS,
AND THAT HAS A CAUSED MIGRANTS
THINKING IT IS EASIER TO CROSS
THE BORDER.
WHAT YOU GUYS DID WAS WITH LINK
TRADE WITH MIGRATION.
YOU TOLD MEXICO ESCALATING
TARIFFS UNLESS YOU CRACK DOWN,
AND THEN YOU HAD MUTUAL RESPECT
FOR EACH OTHER, AND YOU BEGAN TO
CRACK DOWN,, AND THINGS SLOWED
DOWN.
THAT HAS BEEN DRAMATICALLY
REVERSED.
AND THAT’S WHAT WE’RE WITNESSING
NOW.
AND IF YOU COULD TELL ME ABOUT A
SYSTEM THAT ACTUALLY ALLOWED
1600 ILL ILLEGALS THE COME
THROUGH THE YUMA SECTION AND
2200 TO COME THROUGH THE RIO
GRANDE VALLEY OVER THE WEEKEND,
PLEASE TELL ME HOW THAT IS
BETTER.
TO ME, IT IS TO NOT BETTER.
THEY’RE JUST BUILDING ADDITIONAL
HOUSING FOR THESE ILLEGALS WHO
BELIEVE SCHOOL’S OUT.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THE MEN AND WOMEN OF BORDER
PATROL SEE THIS, AND WHEN THEY
SEE THEIR LEADERSHIP AT THE
DEPARTMENT OR LEADERSHIP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE SAY THE BORDER IS
CLOSED AND THE BORDER SECURE AND
THEN THE NUMBERS, BRIAN, YOU
JUST ANTICIPATED, THEY KNOW
THAT’S A LIE.
THEY KNOW THAT’S NOT WHAT’S
HAPPENING ON THE GROUND.
SO IT DOESN’T MATTER WHAT TYPE
OF MESSAGING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO SAY TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, THE FACTS
ON THE GROUND MATTER, AND
THEY’RE TELLING US THE TRUTH.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
>> THAT BORDER CONTINUES TO BE
OPEN BECAUSE OF THE POLICIES
THAT HAVE BEEN PUT IN PLACE.
BUT YOU’RE EXACTLY RIGHT, WE
WORKED WITH MEXICO AND THE
NORTHERN TRIANGLE TO SIGN OVER A
DOZEN AGREEMENTS TO ADDRESS THAT
SECURITY, THAT PROSPERITY ISSUE.
BRIAN: RIGHT.
AND REAL QUICK, KIDS AND
TEACHERS IN HOUSTON ARE
OVERWHELMED BECAUSE THESE KIDS
ARE COMING IN, ENGLISH IS A
SECOND LANGUAGE, AND NOW THEY’RE
OVERCROWDING ALL THESE
CLASSROOMS.
YOU KNOW THESE CHAIN OF EVENTS
ARE HAPPENING ACROSS THE COUNTRY
NOW, RIGHT?
>> WELL, ABSOLUTELY.
AND, AGAIN, YOU KNOW, AS WE SAY,
THE BORDER, BORDER TOWNS ARE NOT
JUST ALONG THE BORDER, THEY’RE
EVERYWHERE, AND THEY’RE ACROSS
AMERICA.
AS THREE KIDS AND FAMILIES COME
INTO THE UNITED STATES, THEY
DON’T JUST STAY ALONG THE
BORDER.
THEY GO INTO MAJOR METROPOLITAN
AREAS, AND YOU’RE PUTTING STRAIN
ON AMERICAN SCHOOLS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, AND THAT’S SOMETHING WE
CERTAINLY NEED TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
BRIAN: CHAD, YOU’VE GOT TO KEEP